Embora os computadores quânticos não sejam adequados para resolver
todos os problemas, existem algumas classes de problemas
e casos de uso potenciais nos quais esperamos que
a computação quântica cause impacto.
Esses incluem simulação, como
modelagem de processos e sistemas que ocorrem na
natureza, busca e otimização,
que envolve encontrar a melhor ou
a solução ideal em uma situação com
muitas respostas possíveis, e matemática
e processamento de dados com estrutura complexa,
incluindo aplicações para aprendizado de máquina.
Os algoritmos quânticos adotam uma nova abordagem para
esse tipo de problema, aproveitando
as características únicas da física quântica, como
superposição, interferência e entrelaçamento.
Computadores convencionais ficam presos
ao explorar certas regiões do espaço computacional,
por isso não conseguem encontrar esses padrões.
Os computadores quânticos estão equipados com
capacidades extras ou desempenho aumentado
para alguns problemas, proporcionado pela sua natureza quântica.
Para entender completamente o potencial dos computadores quânticos,
é necessário mergulhar fundo na teoria da complexidade computacional,
um ramo da ciência da computação focado em
medir e comparar o esforço computacional necessário
para resolver diferentes tipos de problemas.
Isso fornece uma estrutura útil
para descrever várias acelerações
e classes de problemas encontradas na
computação.